one sport that has already made changes
in light of the protests against racial
injustice is NASCAR last month the
racing organization banned the
confederate flag from flying at its race
it's NASCAR made the move two days after
it's a lone black driver Bubba Wallace
called for the flags removal but
speaking out on social issues is new for
the 26 year old driver I spoke with him
about his newfound role as an athlete
and activist as you well know four years
ago Colin Kaepernick's began the meal
during the national anthem and that was
a protest against a racial injustice and
police brutality and it didn't go didn't
end so well for him what are your
thoughts on on Colin and the courage
that it took for him to take that stand
taking your stand the way you did and
receiving quite the opposite reaction I
remember when you know Colin Kaepernick
kneel for the first time and and I knew
the type of message that it set out but
I did not understand at the time I
didn't understand what was being done
and why was being done and it quickly
became a conversation of all sports and
I took the time to educate myself and
see that one it has nothing to do with
disrespecting our military has nothing
to do with disrespecting our flag
it is simply saying you will not stand
prouder for what's going on in this
world today with the oppression of black
people on how our African race is
treated but people don't want to realize
that that's what it is they simply see
it as disrespecting the flag in the
military when people of the military
have stepped up and said this has
nothing to do with disrespecting our
flag or our military or the country I
have fought for we had a powerful moment
at Atlanta where a NASCAR official Curt
price a former military member fought
for our country took a meal if that
doesn't speak volumes to you then those
are the types of people that will never
change and it's just like you're missing
the point you're missing the boat here
you can see the rest of our interview
today on CBS Sports connected that's
right on CBS sports it airs right here
on CBS at 1:00 p.m. Eastern